[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
number one best-selling author yeah
ramsey personality dr john deloney joins
me
this hour this day as my co-host we're
going to help people build wealth do
work that they love and create
absolutely amazing and real
relationships so this is the first time
you've been back on the air with me
anyway uh since you officially
made
own your past change your future a
number one best seller pretty cool huh
it's very cool very proud of you thank
you man i appreciate all your help
getting the thing out there
very well done and what that means is
the not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
is helping a lot
tens of thousands of people in the first
week that it came out and uh the sales
have been
astronomical thank you guys out there
all of you you're the ones actually that
made it a number one uh but uh the fact
that
that you dr john had something to say
that people need to hear yeah uh this
idea own your past and change your
future and
you know i kind of think uh the that the
subject matters caught caught a wave of
i'm hearing a lot of other stuff said
the same the same stuff said different
ways from coming from a lot of people
right now yeah i think there's about 15
or 20 years of
research and practice and people just so
frustrated
and there's been some constriction on
you know by by these
national groups like we don't say this
and we don't say that and i think people
are starting to peel off and say
enough's enough we gotta do something
different yeah well in terms of the uh
the psychological jargon and the nurse
the nerd world but i'm more saying that
you know coming out of covid coming out
of
uh you know and coming headlong into
inflation headlong into interest rates
raising gas prices are ridiculous
political political climate's completely
unstable
uh in the middle of all that a lot of
people are going now wait a minute yeah
you know all this stuff i've been
feeling
uh all these um
i mean the gears are the oils out of the
engine the water whatever the water's
out of the tank whatever whatever phrase
you want to use and i'm i'm down to
nothing i'm empty
and uh so owning your past owning what
we've all just been through is part of
walking out of this not just through it
that's right and then deciding like
what am i going to do next yeah and i've
and i think i'm hoping that we're
reaching a tipping point or have already
fallen over the edge of
i've got to stop going to this
electronic box or this media system or
this entertainment system to try to fill
in those gaps to try to
numb myself through these days i need to
go back to doing things like moving my
body and being around people that i love
and laughing and going bowling again for
god's sake doing some things together
right if you're living on the news
channels you are perpetually afraid or
perpetually angry or both you're
choosing misery that's i mean i'm
choosing to be more miserable the same
thing is true when i you know the only
relationships i have are a smartphone in
my hand and those aren't real
relationships right
and so people i think people are waking
up to that i think there's i think
there's a relationship revolution
facebook stock is down yeah you know
it's people are waking up going those
aren't real friends yeah or they were at
one time and we shared some funny
memories but i've got to live in my
neighborhood today right now yeah and it
turns out the guy i knew in high school
and i like him he's fine but he's not my
best friend anymore don't really care
that's right i don't and hey uh we threw
the gauntlet down for dallas
dallas showed up man yeah they did and
here's the thing both in phoenix and in
dallas we got together for book signings
and talking
i i was at places as varied as i spoke
at the university of north texas health
science center to their medical to the
faculty and administrators and students
of the medical school and then i spoke
to u-haul and i spoke to a group of
people who run a coffee company dutch
bro everybody in between
everybody's wrestling with the same
stuff yep and it's it's time for
collectively to say you know what i'm
putting all the notes i'm turning the
off buttons off and we're going to get
together yep we're just going to get
together the the energy in the room was
not cond
far exceeded how good this book is let
me say that there was people ready to
get back together
whether they're going to they're going
to burn it down whether it's a mosh pit
or it's a barnes and noble they're
getting together and i'm just excited to
be out here in this moment it's the
truth it's the truth the book is own
your past change your future the phone
number here triple eight eight two five
five two two five brittany starts this
hour in canada hi brittany how are you
hello dave hello dr john i'm feeling
great today how are you better than we
deserve what's up
i'm glad to hear it well i just found
out last night that i got into law
school wow so
yeah i'm very excited i've worked so
hard for this and you know put myself
through um
university while being a single mother
and i'm working full time to save up to
cash flow law school um however prior to
learning of my acceptance just last
night i was throwing around the idea of
taking the mortgage broker training
which only cost 500
versus the
law school tuition at 20k per year and
i'm starting to now that i'm i am
excited but i'm feeling a little bit
nervous because it is such a huge
financial commitment and i just kind of
wanted to walk through that with you and
get some insights
i have worked with
i mean i was the dean of students at a
law school so i've got a insider view of
that
i don't know a lot about mortgage
brokers i can let dave speak to that
what i would tell you is if you have the
opportunity to cash flow law school and
be a licensed attorney and that's
something that you have passion and
interest in whether it's you want to
help people navigate complex contract
issues you want to help innocent people
get out of jail um you want to be like
protect whatever the reason is
man there is there's few investments
more powerful there's few positions more
powerful than having a um being a
licensed attorney you can help people in
ways that many guys like me can't
the other side of that is people go to
law school because they want prestige
they want to be rich and the data is
showing us that that's not the case for
the vast majority of attorneys they're
getting out and they're getting out with
a ton of debt and they're making 65 to
85 000 bucks a year here in the u.s
and it's just a slog it's a hard hard
job and so i think you have to ask
yourself why would i want to do that um
if you had the money and you said i
really want to be attorney i would
high-five you all the way dave i don't
know about mortgage brokers as an
outsider the last industry i want to get
into when i'm looking down the barrel
the next 24 36 months is is dealing with
with uh
you know finance of you know any kind of
trading or any of that kind of stuff
but i may be off there yeah i talked to
a guy yesterday in phoenix that
the mortgage broker he worked for
laid off a hundred of them thursday
because with interest rates ticking up
the
refi have slowed way down
and a lot of their business was based on
refi
more so than purchases and purchases
slowed down because there's no inventory
so um
regardless of that mortgage brokering is
a valid
uh long-term career plan now maybe it
might be a hard six months or something
coming up but it's a valid long-term
career plan if that's what you want to
do but that isn't what i'm concerned
about just in the way you told the story
i've always dreamed of i was so excited
when i finally everything was perfect
when i got lost school
oh wait a minute there's there's a
mortgage broker squirrel
squirrel
and i you kind of sound like a dog
chasing a car and you caught it and
didn't know what to do
yeah
i think i think it's i think it scared
you a little bit that now you've got to
live this dream that you've been working
hard a little bit and i think you throw
your shoulders back have some courage
and go be a lawyer
yeah that's just that's just papa dave
talking that's not necessarily career
advice i was just listening to the way
you talked it through that's all
this is the ramsay shaft
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number one best-selling author and
ramsey personality dr john deloney is my
co-host today well it's event week you
guys hey las vegas i hope you're ready
because we're gonna be seeing you guys
for a building wealth
live event in just two days we will be
there this thursday evening dr john
dolony ken coleman rachel cruz george
camel and hi if you haven't reserved
your seats yet what are you waiting for
come see us it's going to be an
action-packed night we're going to walk
you through the crazy stuff going on out
there in the world of money teach you
how to build real wealth and we're going
to have a good discussion with all the
ramsey personalities about what's going
on out here in the society in general
this culture is something that we all
have to learn to walk around in right
now without losing our principles and
also not losing our freaking minds in
the process
so again rachel cruz george campbell dr
john dolone ken coleman hosting a free
bonus session about work and
relationships before the event you don't
want to miss that vegas there are some
seats left we'll still we still can see
you on thursday orlando same situation
orlando's very close to being sold out
it's in two weeks
and we're coming to see you very very
quickly and then in the fall we have
launched uh the building wealth series
in sacramento minneapolis and san
antonio in november
110 and 15 respectively tickets are 25
for any of these building wealth events
a four pack is 60
so uh get a couple of your friends
comments less than the cost of a pizza
so gonna be a lot of fun you'll learn
stuff you'll come away inspired informed
you'll have new information you didn't
have before and uh you you'll go home
thinking you know what i can do this
ramsay solutions dot com slash events to
get your tickets right now our question
of the day comes from blinds.com find
out for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping with the new promos they run
all the time you save even more the
promo code is ramsey
today's question comes from marissa in
new mexico marissa writes i introduced
the baby steps to my ex-boyfriend we
were in an emotionally unhealthy
relationship but decided to live
together
we opened a joint emergency fund account
and a joint checking account to pay our
bills and we both
brought 10 000 to the emergency fund he
had no debt but i owed 4 800 bucks when
we opened the checking account so we
paid that off we broke up last week and
now he wants the money back he's calling
me a thief a scammer and is threatening
to post on social that i used all his
money i'm afraid he will make me lose my
job or go to my daughter's school to
post signs saying i'm a thief
i want to do the right thing but it
seems like since we paid the debt when
we decided to join our incomes i do not
owe him anything even if we broke up two
weeks after what is your advice
who so
sometimes dave people get tied up in
these relationships and it gets real
close and you're someone's telling me a
story and i'll stop them
and say hey
that's harassment or that's abuse and
you watch the light bulb go on and they
go oh i did
oh
right
and so i think there's something to be
said we're going to have the
conversation about money but if you are
afraid that somebody is going to make
you lose your job if you're afraid that
someone's going to go to your kid's
school and harass them embarrass you
then you need to call the authorities
and get people involved in this
conversation because this is bigger than
you this is different than just a bad
breakup this is somebody who's you're
afraid is going to actively try to seek
to destroy your life
so there's my little discussion on that
dave all right so help me with this
question dave what do you think
well i i
um
i i grew up in a neighborhood where the
first thing we learned was what you do
with a bully as you hit them in the nose
you don't
give them more power right you take
their power away immediately
and so that's my redneck reaction
it's your new book that's my neck
reaction
reaction that's it just pop them in the
nose and then then they can stop and
think about their mouth okay
um but the of course we're not
literally physically recommending that
these days but um
yeah that that happened in a different
generation and um
but it sets it does set the dna of
something like this so consequently i
still to this day i i
don't uh do a good job i don't always
use good wisdom when i'm dealing with a
bully
because my first reaction is just game
on you know uh and that's not always the
best reaction yeah so that's what we're
dealing with here this guy's a bully
that's right
and um
so i i don't want you to pay the 4 800
even if i thought you owed it right now
because your reason for doing it is fear
and that is not the right reason to do
it if you want to pay the 4 800 your
reason for doing it needs to be on
principle that you feel like yeah i owe
him that money i owe him that money
because the way this deal went down it's
not right and i should do it right um
and i kind of think that's true yeah i
kind of think you do owe him the money
but uh but i don't want you to do it
until your heart rate changes and drops
down because right now your heart's
beating a thousand miles a minute
because you're scared of somebody yeah
right and and that's
and he thinks and i actually don't want
him to think he got the money because of
that he does he because he bowed up on
you yeah and it's like
he's gonna he's gonna threaten you and
because then what's he gonna threaten
you for next time that's right you know
and so
but um and and
so
and the other part of this is the
the the the
and you can speak to this better than i
can but
we were in an emotionally unhealthy
relationship but we moved in together
anyway which you know what that tells me
it tells me you're gonna go back yeah or
you're gonna find another emotionally
unhealthy you're gonna go back you're
gonna go back to this guy if you're not
careful and so what i want for you is
for him to never
see you speak to you or have any voices
in your head ever again correct when
this is done right uh and the next time
you see an unhealthy relationship i want
you to go no wait i'm a princess
i'm valuable
and i'm i'm so valuable that i don't
need to be entering into an unhealthy
relationship translation i don't need to
sleep with a bully all right and so
here's a couple things you can do you
can go to your boss ahead of time and
say hey um here's a good example this
actually happened dave a year ago um
something back from my past came up and
i call i emailed you right away and said
hey just so you know everything's clear
here this came up and i i preemptively
got ahead of this that right i came and
told you it ended up being nothing
nothing being a thing but i'd go to my
boss and say hey
i've got an out of control somebody's
and
ex-boyfriend
he's
know if he's going to see you or not but
just in case he did just know you just
need to know this guy's a bozo and he'll
come in looking like a clown and you'll
know he's a clown that's right
same with the school hey if this guy
comes around call
and remove him 911
so forth and just just be on on guard
and i've al and also i've already let
the authorities know and i'm filing for
a restraining order that's right um now
once you've done all that then then
don't go back
and don't find another one to replace
him okay
so you know what do you any time i do
something stupid i try to figure out
what it was
so i don't do it again
if i'm gonna do stupid stuff it needs to
be new stupid stuff
okay that's your next book new stupid
stuff by dave ramsey we got a lot of
books coming out today okay number one
bestsellers everywhere redneck reaction
and yeah new stupid stuff but stupid
stuff but the uh uh but you know the
thing is that
i i think there's a tremendous
statistical probability that she cycles
back if she doesn't break the mold on
this that's right and and it feels like
uh marissa you're trying to soft land
this thing yeah and you want to that's
fair keep this guy in the relationship
you want to figure out how to keep your
money but not have to do it's all about
you're terrified
i want you to stone cold this guy yeah
and give him the money back block him on
everything okay so let's get into that
they got together well they shouldn't
have done any of this yeah i read um i
introduced them to your baby steps i
want to say no you didn't you like a
weird part of the baby steps well you
made you up your own plan where we can
live together in an unhealthy
relationship and then combine our money
when we're not married that we have
never told anybody anything except never
do that because of this because of this
right here moment this is what happens
when you shack up with people you aren't
married to and you play house
because you want to wear the shoes for a
week before you actually buy them so
i've got no debt i owe 400 bucks they
paid it he he paid it off
technically i think they both they're
10k in there so there's 20 grand in
there and then they paid off 4 800 out
of that sounds like
she splits it he needs to get his 10
grand back total
and it's probably down by something
yeah and then but kiddo
love yourself enough
put the stiff arm on the bozo
permanently block him on everything and
anybody that even smells like him ever
again
oh wait a minute wait a minute that i
smell bozo no
walk away
[Music]
[Music]
so
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage mike
and cat are with us hey guys how are you
good how are you good welcome where do
you guys live
cape cod it's complicated at the moment
okay cape cod i'm going with it run with
it i love it i love it well i got to
visit there back in the fall for the
first time in my life and i absolutely
loved it beautiful area it is absolutely
a lot of fun well welcome to nashville
and you're here to do a debt-free scream
how much have you paid off
206 000. whoa how long did this take 31
months to had gum and your range of
income during that time
we went from uh 67 to 256 000. in two
and a half years yes sir that's a story
in and of itself what do you guys do for
a living and what in the world happened
to your income
um i went from delivering beer
to driving entertainment
um
personnel put it that way okay all right
and i went from trying to run a small
business just out of college doing about
17 000 a year to realizing i was
terrible at it and throwing the baby out
with the bathwater and going back to the
drawing board and i'm now a project
manager oh very good very very good okay
wow so both of you maximized your
careers during this period of time
obviously changed directions when a lot
of different stuff so it sounds like you
do a little bit of personal security as
well mike yes okay all right perfect
good for you what kind of debt was the
206 000 who everything everything you
name it we had credit cards we had legal
fees we had irs debt we had we had a
chur
a lot between the two of us
um that was i would say literally
everything
y'all were kind of normal
yeah normal like a mess yeah like a hot
mess i didn't even realize it
how long you've been married
oh a little while now we uh we haven't
had the ceremony yet during all this
process so
to me not not yet because i want that
big party eventually okay all right
we've got the paper here's the paper and
the kids we're working on the uh
celebrating part
okay all right so we have circle back on
that okay all right the uh
what got all this started 31 months ago
where you say uh this ramsay stuff this
hillbilly down south we gotta check this
out i'm gonna blame it on her
good good like blaming it on her
we did about 10 months of [ __ ] prior i
had a book from my ex-fiance's father
called toto money makeover hanging out
on my shelf and i had tried to
get a mortgage doing all the paperwork
and realized we were not going to do
well
and i finally sat down and read said
book and in the book was a thousand
dollars for baby step one as i finally
read what had been on my shelf for five
years
so that was the beginning of the end and
realizing like i needed to get him on
board and
what we could do to get there and that
we needed a bigger shovel mike she walks
in with all these ideas what'd you say
um they looked and was like this is
impossible
absolutely not and then i
kind of
i cash flowed a lawyer and was like oh i
can actually do this it's the first time
i've ever cash flowed a lawyer i've
always had to pay for
pay for it out of uh get a loan from my
mother or get a loan from somebody else
like a friend and uh that was pretty
much when i cash flowed i was like i can
actually do this
oh oh my god i can do this all right so
then it started going let's do this
let's do this and
having her pretty much be the nerd of
the whole thing
i'm the free i'm the free spirit i'm i
want to let's go here let's go travel i
want to go places and she was just like
no we have to hammer down and buckle
down so that's pretty much it
that's what i started jumping on and uh
drinking the kool-aid yeah so when you
start working you're like gotta do it
yeah every emergency we cashflowed got
him a little bit more through the door
it sounds like y'all have been living
emergency to emergency for the last
however many years what was it like
finally i mean y'all went from making
getting by to making stupid money what's
it like
really crossing that financial threshold
but then all of a sudden you've got her
saying
we've got a key hey we got to keep
grinding got to keep grinding
it's got to be hard
it's so hard but it's like to look at it
having her being like we're going to be
debt-free we're going to live we can go
wherever we want once we're debt-free we
can go wherever we want we can do
whatever we want once we're debt-free
giving up the jeep for him i think was
the hardest part oh you sold his jeep
yes
and we sold it under 3 000 we still had
to pay off 3 000 when we sold it
i went upside down on it how much how
much did it sell for
uh it went for about 22 it was pretty
all the crazy
so it went for about 22 and we we still
owed 27 on it
so it was rough
ouch
okay but it's gone and now we get them
on to the next thing and do the next
thing and onto the next thing
and but i i i think john was recognizing
something that i saw too and the way you
all were talking about this you went
from a place where most of your life
money had happened to you
and now you start happening to it money
started yes you kind of went over the
edge and you went now we're in control
by god yes this stuff's not going to
boss me around i'm going to boss it
around exactly so i was in a place of my
life when this all started where i was
literally paying 45 on a credit card to
get it down from that maximum to buy
groceries or put gas in the car and then
it would max back out and then i'd pay
the next one off because that was the
one that was due that month and it was
not paycheck to paycheck it was credit
card payment to credit card payments
hide the p yes exactly i had to pay
under a shell what is it
for two folks who have never experienced
this
what's what's
explain in your own words what does it
feel like on the other side of this
thing like you're completely now that
you're free i'm weightless yeah but i i
literally have no stress on my shoulders
i'm like whatever
like oh i can go here you know we came
to nashville like oh let's go to
nashville like okay let's go no problem
whereas i'm confused and stressed out
and trying to figure out what to do now
that i have managed to accomplish all
the little bullet points on my list and
it's amazing but it's like all of a
sudden looking at baby step three and it
happened so quickly and now we're into
3b trying to save for a house and it's
just kind of a what's next it's wild
yeah you're you're you've done amazing
incredible
because here's what happened um you
didn't just get your money straight you
transformed
the way you look at it the way you think
about it there's a heart transformation
that occurred just looking at the two
you can see it on your face you can see
in your body language it's impressive
you guys are heroes you did some really
hard work is what i'm saying thank you
this is i i can see it i mean some
people are just like oh we're going to
do this thing but you guys went from
live to we're in control that's right
and that's from i'm going to keep
running this business no matter what no
matter what no matter what to
i got to look in the mirror and say
what's reality here and i got to do
something different project manager
hey i don't know how you figured out how
to that making more money delivering
people than beer but congratulations on
that thank you well done but now hey now
you're not planning on delivering people
full of beer that's right
very similar but now you can decide if a
job comes by and you're like some of my
gut says i'm not i'm gonna pass you can
pass exactly right
totally you could pass that's freedom
that's freedom man i don't have to worry
about sitting back and being like oh do
i i have to go to work today yeah i can
i go no i'm going to pass that tour off
or i'm going to pass that that project
off you know awesome those aren't people
i think i want to work with this week
yeah right
down playing it because he went through
three job changes trying to get there he
went from beer delivery to tours on the
road and wanted to come back for family
when we had that then attempted his
dream at firefighter we did a lot of ken
coleman listening to in this and
realized he wanted the money and went
back into entertainment and so he really
really threw everything out and started
over yes both of you did yeah it was
powerful incredible guys
i love it we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that is the next
chapter in your story for sure no doubt
you are on track to do that and uh we'll
give you another copy of total money
makeover you can give it someone to sit
on their shelf and five years from now
they'll pull it off at exactly the right
time right it is the uh the
the world's best-selling uh coffee table
table coaster holds lots of coffee cups
all over america until just the right
moment when it opens up so proud of you
guys very very very well done good stuff
and the kiddos names and ages i
understand they're sitting off to the
side yes they are we have ryder who's
three and liliana who is two months oh
fun very very cool all right it's mike
and cat with a complete transformation
while they pay off 206
000.31 months making from 67 to 256.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two
one
i love it
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
my co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five
warren buffett is quoted as saying he
wouldn't take all the bitcoin in the
world for 25 dollars
that might be a bit of an indictment
folks i don't know we've been telling
you not to buy that stuff from day one
well dave anybody over the age of 58 is
clearly out of touch as a dinosaur and
doesn't know what they're doing and even
if you happen to be one of the richest
men in the world
of your financial
acumen acumen but
aside from that um idiot yeah he's an
idiot he doesn't know what he's doing
and the fact that bitcoin's gone from
what fifty thousand to
thirty
two it's having a rough few weeks 20
minutes it's like when when you're on
the back end of the largest uh bull run
i don't know
on the planet's history and
people started creating imaginary things
to sell it's awesome and then all sudden
when gas is expensive and food is
expensive
imaginary things aren't so fun anymore
oh the unicorns come crashing down it
turns out the uh nfts and the bitcoins
are imaginary
virtual means not really sorta kinda
almost
if i virtually send my wife flowers she
doesn't like it
i meant to but they didn't quite get
there
all right andrew's in atlanta georgia hi
andrew welcome to the ramsey show
hey how are you guys doing better than i
deserve what's up
all right so
um i have about fifteen hundred dollars
in credit card debt i'm cutting it down
not using that credit card anymore
um but my question is i have sixteen
hundred and ninety four dollars in
interest free
credit card debt it's interest-free for
33 more months it's equipment for my
music stuff i'm a musician and i do
stuff like that so i was just wondering
what should i take first
uh what should i do with that
interest-free debt should i just pay the
payments till it's done or just pay it
off
okay
well so you have 1600 in debt and you
have how much other debt
uh that's that's the only date i have
you only have sixteen hundred dollars in
debt that's your all your that's that's
in the interest free yeah no i'm saying
period period any kind of debt you have
a student loan card debt
other credit cards no student loans no
card debt so get a paid off car so total
with the interest rate and the one with
interest i have about three thousand
dollars in that okay
all right and and your household income
is what
uh i make about sixteen hundred or
sixteen thousand a year
okay with that that's including
music stuff and my part-time job as well
i'm a full-time student so oh okay
there's that okay because i was getting
ready to say your job sucks okay
um a full-time job making 16k put you at
the poverty level so we don't want to
call that a career track okay
uh so we need to so what are you going
to do when are you getting out of school
what's your plan
i've got about two years left in school
i'm still at home so i don't have any
rent
i don't have i don't have a mortgage or
anything like that
after that um
what are you studying graduating
uh marketing good okay so i want to go
into sales so you're a college student
that lives at home with three thousand
dollars in debt and how how is school
paid for
my father pays for that very nice okay
are you running up are you buying music
equipment are you playing shows on the
weekend trying to make it or is it just
a hobby
no yeah that i mean that was that's the
dream but i also want a backup plan
because i don't want to you know go move
up to nashville and uh
you know
not make it and be stuck i'd be stuck at
that point
yeah how do you get the next country
music star's attention in nashville
uh waiter yeah so um
uh
all right
okay
number one you got a good overall plan
number two if you're making sixteen
hundred dollars
or seventeen thousand dollars a year you
should pay this debt off with no way out
of pocket expenses to mount anything
very very quickly would you agree with
me that you're gonna be done with the
entire amount of debt within three to
six months is that doable it is isn't it
yeah yeah no i don't think so okay and
so really the interest rate doesn't
matter because you're gonna be done in
three to six months now what we teach to
answer your question technically andrew
is to list your debts smallest to
largest
and uh sounds like they're about the
same size
regardless of interest rate pay minimum
payments on
everything but your smallest debt attack
the smallest debt first regardless of
interest rate so the fact that it's a
zero percent interest does not impress
me does not change the order in which i
pay it off i would pay off the smallest
one first regardless of the interest
rate because i want you to have the
emotional advantage of traction
seeing that you're starting to win
rather than living off of these credit
cards you're putting them under your
heel and grinding them
and being done with them and that's the
big thing but it sounds like these are
very similar i mean if they're both
sixteen seventeen hundred dollars each
then then you got three thousand dollars
total then you know just uh you can put
whichever one you want first but be done
with the whole thing in six months
but let's just say you had ten different
debts and one of them was a thousand one
of them was ten thousand uh
but the the the one thousand was
interest free would i still put it first
yes i would because i want you to get
the traction the advantage of this
psychological income of winning it's
called hope and it causes people to
continue to move through this and that's
how
we at ramsey have gotten more people out
of debt than probably any other
organization on the planet
at least currently operating and andrew
let me let me speak to you here
there is a
gibson flying v
electric guitar
that i've been eyeballing for like six
months
and
i can afford it but my wife and i have
made some goals and some plans and so
i'm holding off i'm holding off and now
instagram listens to me and they just
send me these pictures
of the guitar and another one and
another one
you're gonna have to not buy music
equipment for a season just stop
you think you need a new thing for this
and a new i gotta have that you don't
need it there's no end to it there's it
just will continue to consume you and
i'm in the middle of
that myself any people that play music
have an addictive problem for their
instruments
music people car people gun people like
it just happens so you got to stop
buying equipment say i'm not going to
buy another thing piece of gear for
another year and then i'm going to get
out of debt wait if i need another gun
that's different that's that's right
that's right don't get leave the cars
alone right my car is
the same thing you get you get you get
to where
and the truth is there's almost nothing
in america that we buy that qualifies as
a need
very few almost everything we buy
qualifies as a want
very few i mean we pretty much are all
over fed and have too many clothes
and we pretty much all have a place to
sleep so food shelter clothing
transportation we got it covered you
know i mean it's not an issue
and so that's not the problem in america
now there's nothing wrong with spending
money on once
but we just tell folks to be really
careful and be emotionally mature enough
to say
that is a want right
and once
for sure you pay cash for it and for
sure they've got to go in line with your
overall goals yep
yeah yeah so one of the
issues that rachel cruz talks about a
lot and i do too as well we're talking
about teaching kids about money is
teaching them contentment
to learn to sit in what you have and
being good with it um and you know that
how far you could go in the music
business with the music equipment you
already have is amazing yep that's right
and without ever buying another thing
that's right uh it's amazing and uh how
you know i if i could just get that if i
could just get that that's a
discontentment the advertisers and the
marketers job is to create psychological
dissonance
discomfort
in you so that you feel i will be
comfortable when i'll be satiated when
i get that next thing and and you know
that that's the driving force of the
most marketed to advertised to culture
in the history of mankind
in the history of the human race and you
live right square in the middle of it
you and so do i
we see four to eight thousand
advertisements a day
there are advertisements in the bathroom
for god's sakes on the front and the
back of the door they're everywhere
ridiculous you know and so
you're not getting away from it and so
what you have to learn is the spiritual
and emotional
psychological discipline
to say
no no it's a complete sentence i'm not
doing it no
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host number one
best-selling author and ramsey
personality dr john deloney is my
co-host today as we answer your question
about your life and your money open
phones at
825-5225 we help people build wealth do
work that they love
and create real
relationships jacob is with us jacob is
in flint michigan hi jacob how are you
hello i'm doing well good how are you
guys
great man how can we help well uh my
wife and i are followers of your plan
we've paid off all our debt but for our
mortgage
uh but our house burned down this last
saturday oh no
man
what happened
uh i'm not sure yet uh the fire
department thinks it started in the
garage
um i was the only one home at the time
my wife and kids were out of town with
grandparents so i'm uninjured
you know we're okay we'll be doing all
right it's just total loss
i think so you know i'm no expert but i
think it's a total replacement i mean we
got a few things out after the fire was
out but they're all smoke damaged be
damaged
man i've sat in people's front yard with
my arm over the shoulder while we
watched their house burn and the and the
firefighters are there and
that's a traumatic moment man i'm sorry
that happened
i'm real sorry that happened dude
i'm glad you're saying i'm glad you're
safe
yeah the uh the uh cliche thing to say
as well everybody's okay yeah i know
unless you're home man all your stuff's
gone man that's just your memories your
pictures your
things keepsakes and valuables i'm so
sorry
thank you how can we help you walk
through this
well
i guess my question is a little broad i
just i never expected this i hadn't
really thought about it and i i want to
move through this with wisdom
you know so
is there a is there a ramsey way of
moving through a house fire
uh who who is your homeowner's insurance
with
state auto okay all right
i don't have experience with that
particular brand one way or the other um
uh
you don't have to be unkind but you're
gonna have to be very very tough
okay because the uh the the adjuster's
job is to minimize the size of the claim
and he or she works for the insurance
company not for you
okay
you may have to involve a lawyer to get
proper payout you might you could also
involve what's called a public adjuster
meaning you hire an adjuster on your
side of the negotiation that walks you
through every one of the details and
they'll they'll cost a lot but they
usually make you more than they cost you
if they're good at what they do
if you smell trouble immediately run to
one of those two
okay but don't start with the naive
thing that the insurance company loves
you and they want to take care of you
none of that is true
right and d do you have um most
homeowners policies have
you know if it's a total loss then it's
going to be x number of dollars to
replace the home and then there's going
to be some money to give you a place to
live while you're waiting right do you
have you gone through your policy to
find out where you stand
yes yeah i saw our limit for
uh structure
and then our limit for contents and then
we've got some covering housing okay
okay we'll immediately get your housing
done get the families you know uh
emotionally solid in a place to live
where we're not living in a hotel room
as quick as you can because you're gonna
be here a while um then the second thing
i would tell you to do just from this is
just from experience it's not
necessarily a ramsey thing it's just
having again like john having walked
through this with other people
um start making everybody in the family
start making lots and lots and lots of
lists
of everything you can think of that was
in that house
lots of lists
and you're never done making this list
you just keep making it and you don't
let them rush you
to settlement
unless it's at the max that you're going
to get anyway if they want to write you
checks for the max
on the house and on the contents well
you don't have to do a lot of lists
they're just going to write they just
said okay we're going to cover it
but usually you've got to create some
kind of proof
and then they want to argue about every
freaking little item on that list as to
how much it's depreciated
and all of this and so i wish i could
give you good news and say this was
going to be an easy thing
no there's two different sets of trauma
that's happened here one is the fire and
all that they all the emotions that go
with that and the loss and then there's
another set of trauma and that's going
to be dealing with the insurance company
uh it's you know i wish i could tell you
it wasn't going to be that if it's not
um
then you found the best insurance
company on the planet but i can tell you
the vast majority of them are an
absolute
pain in the butt to go through this
process with and so you've got to
uh
take control of the narrative take
control of the discussion by constantly
pushing constantly raising constantly
moving the timeline along uh and and you
know well we're gonna use our uh
you know contractor well maybe we're not
that's right there's nothing in the
policy that says we're gonna use your
contractor
so maybe we're going to use my
contractor and so i'm going to control
the narrative i'm going to control
the discussion and the decisions i'm not
going to assume
um i mean i don't want you to be mean to
them again but but you need to be taught
you have to be tough you have to be
really really strong um if you need to
be mean you can but uh but but at first
you just need to be really really strong
and don't
make the assumption that just because
they're nice
or just because they're kind or they
they speak slow or low
that which they're trained to do that
that's gonna
immediately mean you don't come up a
hundred thousand bucks short when this
is all over of what you should have
gotten because you didn't lean into the
details in the process i would this is
going to sound like um
uh being cliche here and so i would tell
you this if you and i were just hanging
out and i didn't work here
i've heard of one time that somebody had
a
a
a disaster it was during the tornadoes
in nashville a couple years ago and my
buddy was had just switched his
homeowners insurance to xander and he
lost everything and he said it was an
extraordinary experience
it was from start to finish they took
care of him and we had dinner and his
brand new they rebuilt the house from
the floor up dug the whole thing out and
he said it was a
like start to finish was a great
experience but xander wasn't the
insurance company xander was the broker
they were the broker and they stepped in
and also fought on his behalf that's you
gotta you got somebody in your corner
when you got a broker like that they
and they
you know again they do that because of
uh our relationship yeah and so that's
really incredible that makes a lot of
difference but in most cases you know
you're on your own kitchen table yeah
yeah you're just trying to make lists
and you're trying to figure this out and
you're trying to consider the legalities
and
everything else and so don't
you know
and i would just readily you know keep
bringing up to the adjuster look if we
can't come to a reasonable
process on this then we're gonna have to
involve an attorney or we're gonna have
to involve a public adjuster if i if you
and i can't manage this project to get
to a reasonable result then i'm gonna
have to bring in outside people to push
you around if i can't if you and i can't
work this and so you just very calmly
just stay in their grill
the whole time it's gonna be two years
yeah it'll be a two year process
sorry about that sorry brother that's
that's uh we can help anyway you holler
at us this is the ramsay show
[Music]
oh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at
825.5225. we appreciate you being here
well john last time we played your
questions for humans conversation cards
uh you found out uh
my favorite tv shows downton abbey not
true
and uh that there was a murder in my
family and uh
so these cards are selling i'm proud of
them yeah they're selling like crazy man
it's a lot of fun people are
having the it gives them an opportunity
an entrance into a conversation which
they may have not had in a couple of
years so it's good
so um we pulled some other cards out of
here out of the friends deck here okay
all right
so um
let's see here
what's the
what's your favorite cheat meal that
you'll always love no matter how much
money you make
hmm
cheat meal
i'd probably be chocolate doughnuts i
guess
that's not a new meal that's not a meal
no uh pizza i guess yeah pizza yeah from
a certain place yeah just pizza yeah
mine is i kept hearing about it over and
over day after day and finally one night
sheila was out of town i got up in the
car i drove by myself this is years ago
to a local taco bell and i said one
dorito taco please listen
listen man i took one bite of the dorito
taco and i thought america is going to
be okay
if we came up with this we're gonna make
it yeah that your belly is glowing oh
yeah oh dude that's radioactive yeah
not good for you but i'm telling you no
it's not only not good for you it's bad
for you
all right what's the best concert you've
ever been to and why
um
i well i mean i've been to like five
eagles concerts yeah so including hotel
california just the other day how was
that
it's good yeah i mean the boys are
getting older yeah i mean
vince can still sing and they can they
don't miss a lick on a guitar i mean joe
walsh may be one of the best guitars in
the world he can jam so convinced man
and vince right there with him but uh
their their vocals are aging out a
little they were really really good
though they're 90 there yeah still and
vince 100 there he's better glenn fry
than glenn frye was probably
all right and uh who's the worst boss
you ever had and why uh
i guess the guy that came in and told me
to effing get my effing desk cleaned out
and get the effing out of there and i
still don't know why i got fired
it still haunts you yeah you're just
driving along down the highway so i
don't even i'll never know why i got
fired i don't i probably deserve to get
fired i just don't know what i did
i still to this day don't um but that
would drive me crazy yeah i would need
that closure i'm not insecure that that
well i mean it i would want to know like
what did i do a long time ago it was 40
years ago but you know but uh so
consequently people that work at ramsey
always know
why they got fired very close never any
doubt as to what happened you know
you may not like it you may not agree
with it but you will know oh and we're
you're also not gonna be surprised yeah
i was surprised i didn't see it coming
uh you know and so there's that that
goes with it too so yeah that that has
to be the worst boss right
yeah
what about you what about your worst
boss
oh that's tough to answer in front of
all these people
um they might be listening
i had one mine has the benefit of being
dead yeah yours is dead you can say
whatever you want
um i gosh i've i'll tell you this it
sounds so cheesy i have been
so fortunate to have some of the
greatest supervisors ever there's one
that uh get him a dorito taco
no we don't want we don't need that kind
of digestive issues on the radio no
digestive issues there was there was one
supervisor i had that had some
significant integrity issues that
ultimately um that person left
and and so i ended up staying but that
person left and that was that was tough
for me as a young professional
it it uh was a baptism by fire like
i i've had that happen when i've worked
at places but even more so even while
i've owned the place that um that
someone leaves
and uh
as a leader i've told leaders this i've
taught this in entre leadership that
someone leaves and you go okay this
person enough already yeah this is we've
tried everything we've negotiated about
this we've tried to correct the behavior
and but you're worried because they're
real popular with the gang and the gang
doesn't know the whole story yeah and so
when you eject them you think you're
going to get a rebellion right
and when you hit eject but what i've
discovered happens is that the gang does
know yeah and you have what i call the
uh
the wizard of oz syndrome where that
scene in the wizard of oz where dorothy
is throws the water on the wicked witch
it towards the end oh yeah and the old
original israelis right and it's like
what a whale do it well and she smelled
you know she melts and goes through a
trap door on the floor and there's a her
thing and then the oompa loompa guys are
standing around little poodle looking
guys right with their curvy knives and
they're like the
guys right and uh you think they're
going to turn these knives on dorothy
because they just she just killed their
boss yeah and there's this pregnant
pause in the movie like a three beat you
know and it's like oh no they're gonna
turn this is dorothy's toast right here
and then they all drop to one knee and
go all hail dorothy that's right and
that's what they do to the leader who
removes toxic stuff from the
organization thank you so much the team
goes all hell the leader is actually a
leader actually she actually knew what
the flip was going on so yeah that's a
it's a very valuable leadership lesson
to remember that you might have a wizard
of oz moment when you remove
the uh toxic tina from the organization
so uh or whoever it is or toxic tony it
could be i don't know either way
somebody has to be somebody with a t
because we have to alliterate so
[Laughter]
questions for human cards are on sale
they're part of the ten dollar sale at
ramsey right now go to ramsey
ramseysolutions.com
there's a lot of stuff a lot of our
best-selling books etc on sale
for the uh unbelievable price of ten
dollars and lots of number one
best-selling books the questions for
human cards there
check it all out it's absolutely
the best time to get a deal and if you
haven't heard you can enter the ramsey
cash giveaway for a chance to win up to
three thousand dollars no purchase
necessary must be 18 or older to win to
enter the giveaway go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway anna is in pittsburgh hi anna
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi john thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
okay so i am currently teaching fpu at
my church and this week's lesson was on
insurance so it really
got me thinking about my parents and
they do not have long-term care
insurance
and i've talked to them about it a
couple times before they just don't
really seem to be interested
so i just want some advice on
what to do i just want to make sure
they're protected and that i'm protected
as well
well you're not in jeopardy
unless she's the one that's gonna have
to take care of her well if she chooses
not to write the check she's not in
jeopardy yeah
so you know there's no law that says
that you have to write the check for the
nursing home if they don't do what
they're supposed to do
so they'll just have to work it out but
uh
uh
so you're you're technically not in
jeopardy now
uh and and if someone refuses your
advice on getting the proper coverage
and then later on once your money
instead um i think they're disqualified
at that point so
um but uh you know so how do you
convince mom and dad
to do anything it's almost impossible
you really can't and because you've
heard me say it before anna it's the
powdered butt syndrome once someone has
powdered your butt they don't want your
advice on money or sex
and so your parents just aren't going to
listen to you about these things it's
weird i i had this conversation with my
parents here's how i approached it i
said i want to know what y'all's plan is
and what is the plan for
if something was to happen to one of you
and this was a broader like hey let's
talk about the will let's talk about
what is the plan if something happens
and that um i've got great parents and
wise parents and they that sparked a
conversation of
oh we need to come up with a xyz plan
which they got us long-term care
insurance i think for christmas they
they got it and then told all of us as
their kids like hey this is really
expensive so merry christmas y'all
aren't going to have to
have they got it for themselves for
themselves christmas present to you yeah
it's us so you don't have to deal with
it so hey mom and dad you want to give
me a christmas present that'd be one way
to approach it there you go have some
but and i i had the exact same
experience i had a relative that um
actually came and asked my advice and i
told them all the reasons that they
needed to get long-term care insurance
they didn't do it
18 months later
the wife was diagnosed with early onset
alzheimer's
and they didn't have the coverage and
you can't get the coverage then it's
like getting
can't get you know
car insurance after the car wreck it's
not possible so
i would just begin to talk to him about
just say i'm concerned i love you but
you can't make them do it and you're
going to be really disappointed in your
life if you keep trying to
get people to do stuff they don't want
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today elizabeth is with us she
is in
sacramento hi elizabeth i see on my
screen you're completely debt-free way
to go
yes i am and it is so incredible
exciting i love knowing when i go to the
store and i spend money it is mine
love and love it repayments yep me too
how much you pay off
65 000. cool how long did this take you
five years good for you and your range
of income during that time
well when i finally got serious about
getting out of debt it started 11.86
cents and i finished it that just got a
promote wrote promotion last month and
about 50 000 a year good for you wow
good for you that's amazing so what do
you do
i work at a hotel i'm now i'm a
supervisor
cool good for you supervising what
supervising the front staff assisting
guests with any opportunities they may
have with the hotel
great very cool and what kind of uh
debt was the 65 000
it was a combination of uh 25 500 in
student loans
10 000 to the federal government and 29
500 between two credit cards wow
way to go how old are you
i am 44.
so what happened when you were 39 that
was your wake-up call
ugly divorce and
custody issues
and not being able to provide for myself
or my son and just getting myself
more and more debt with credit cards to
make ends meet was sick and tired of
being sick and tired and i ended up
having to let go of my fully furnished
two-bedroom apartment because i just
couldn't afford the rent increases
what was originally
1100 went to 1800 you know within a year
sure that's just ridiculous so
you know it's hard to tell my son i'm
sorry i i can't do that for you baby i
can't afford that i'm sorry
and i just didn't want my debt to make
choices for me anymore so i let go of my
two-bedroom apartment
moved in with a christian family and
friends as a sublet put everything i had
in a 10 by 10 storage unit started
selling it all
i'm glad my son didn't think he was next
my jewelry all my furniture
everything it's now down to like a 5x10
storage unit and i'm still selling stuff
look at you i took odd jobs over time in
fact i volunteered to work the graveyard
shift because it initially paid more an
hour
been with the same company six years and
i uh
took advantage of every free thing that
they offered as the their team members
and employees and i love my company
because they have been a huge part of
that journey that's cool as well as my
accountability partners and making a
budget that is just
too crucial the accountability and the
budget
how did you run into the ramsey stuff
i had first heard about it actually from
my ex-husband um
let's see about
15 years ago i was diagnosed with a
brain tumor and our spring or a portion
of the medical costs and it didn't be
like 40 000
and
that was a huge amount of money for us
and we were already in debt and we're
like well we need to do something
different because what we're doing is
just not working we're just getting into
more holes
so we bought the dvds and did the
classes at home and just as we were
digging ourselves out of the of the
credit cards then
we got a divorce and so i dug myself
back into more credit cards and more
debt with the divorce costs and
everything
and uh
you know i ended up taking fpu twice
through my different my church and aft
with this third time of being sick and
tired of being sick and tired i was like
i'm gonna stop being dave-ish
and be gazelle intense i want to slay
the dragon of my debt
and it sounds like in the process you
just hit ctrl alt delete on your whole
life
everything was turned around
but they've been some of the best worst
experiences of my life and i will never
go back to credit cards
lending borrowing money nothing
what was it like i can't think of
industry
i mean there's there's so many that were
hit hard in the last couple years but
one of the hardest hit was the
hotel industry
what was the stress like trying to keep
this thing going
well i'm fortunate to say we were
attached to a casino a tribal casino in
northern california
so while our industry we did put pause
for six weeks during the pandemic that i
had already started my thousand dollars
step one emergency fund and knowing that
i had that in my back pocket
it just and i was already halfway
through my debt journey that was just i
was sailing through it i was like i'm
gonna take the time and just relax and
enjoy and not work for six weeks and
then get back after used that
yeah we reopened and
i mean we're still having issues as a
hotel with staffing and you know clean
you know we try and keep everything
super clean
the guests may not always understand
that
pre pre and post pendant expectations
can't you know they're different
right but uh well good for you i'm so
i'm so
there's a few fewer harder things than a
single mom who says all right i gotta i
just gotta do this all over and i gotta
start with myself and i gotta make this
thing happen and you did and it's it's
just it's inspiring it's incredible very
well done we're proud of you
good job elizabeth i love me too
thank you thank you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
make a plan i recommend the ramsey pro
step but if they want to follow
something else just find something that
works for you make a plan
get an accountability partner and budget
and then if you can cut that budget i
i had you know my bare minimum budget
and then i was like because i don't
drive for medical reasons i was like i
can't afford to lift an uber
so i cut my lift an uber out of my life
i started walking more taking public
transit and i with my county partner
figured out that i can pay my friends
hey how'd you like to make some extra
money
driving me around town
and so thankfully when the bus is not
available and
i can't walk home with two bricks with
the groceries
they uh
they graciously pick me up and lyft and
uber is now
a distant third option convenient option
but you know it's not my first choice
yeah
that's powerful yeah dude you get
creative when you want out and you gotta
work it and you worked it oh yeah very
very well done hey we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story you are on
your way you have uh turned the corner
for sure you've climbed your way up out
of the valley and uh you are heading
across the top of the mountain well done
uh also a copy of total money makeover
you can give it away to somebody there
in the hotel or some friend that's been
helping you with driving around maybe
you can start a holy ruckus in their
life that'd be good stuff oh
i've already done that i've had like
several copies with your ten dollar
sales and i hand them out like candy
first taste is free well thank you thank
you very very much very well done
all right it's elizabeth in sacramento
65 000 paid off in five years
making a 11.86 all the way to 50 000
bucks a year count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
wow
[Music]
yeah just in case you're sitting there
making 82 000 a year with two car
payments whining
that you can't figure out a way to do
this along comes elizabeth and mike
drops on your head
right or you're living in some giant
metropolitan city and you think that the
world should bring the rent down for you
because you deserve to live in this town
along comes elizabeth and says i'll take
the night shift and i can't live in the
eighteen hundred so i'm moving down to
the left i'm moving moving out i'll live
in this other place i'll put all my
stuff in a box and sell it
good for her just because i'm in
sacramento i don't get a pass on math
i'm gonna do what it takes it's a it's a
different
there's something about people when they
get up above a problem and stand on it
rather than laying under it yes and it's
victor versus victim man and we all can
do both yeah we all have a tendency to
both yeah
but it is a conscious decision to get
above it and go no
not today problem today i own you big
brain tumor
ugly divorce single mom
make it 11 bucks
to i'm turning this whole thing around
it's never too late to start over yeah
and i got friends and i got a great
place to work taking care of me game on
and family helping me and a christian
family my church taking me in
letting me sublet oh my gosh people all
around are helping her
this is the ramsay shop
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
caitlin is with us on the line open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john delony ramsey
personality
is my co-host today caitlin's in
washington dc hi caitlin how are you
hey good thank you for helping me out
with my question sure how can we help
okay so um my husband and i just
recently relocated from his job and we
moved from our my dream house and our
dream location to this area
why did you all destroy your dream
it's um just for his first job it's
better it's better it's a better job so
okay anyway
so how can we know it was good that was
good and it's not that bad it really
isn't um it's growing on me but so my
question is um we're gonna close on our
home we're selling at the end of this
month
we
are selling it for 9.25 and we bought it
for 5.69
we owed around 228 on it
so when all is said and done we should
make about 680.
um here we have purchased a townhome
which is much smaller it's really nice
but it's not you know our forever home
so my question is
when we do get that money
should we pay off the town home we would
then become totally debt-free
um we owe about okay
okay we owe about 311 on this now for to
pay that off and then um our
our hope is to build um we're not sure
where we kind of want to see where we're
going to be at
so we just want to make the right
decision and then possibly keep this and
then maybe rent it out in the future
only if you can build with cash and keep
that with cash
okay if you have to sell that to keep
from taking out a mortgage
then you will sell it then you will sell
it okay okay but um but i'm going to go
ahead and pay it off now you've got the
peace and the stability of no debt
you've got this tremendous cash flow
with this wonderful new job
and you're going to use all of it to
pile up cash in addition to what you've
got left over from the sale of the dream
home back at the other location and all
of that is moving towards building
another dream home
another home that you think you guys
adore and love and hopefully between the
sale of the townhouse and the cash that
you save and have saved from the other
house you can pay cash for the new house
if you can do that and keep the paid for
townhouse as a rental fine
but again we're not going to keep the
how town house and then go borrow money
on your new place
because that's in effect borrowing money
to buy rental property and we're not
doing that
right
so that's your plan congratulations what
a big windfall it's that's a great man
one the bad news is you sold your dream
house the good news is you made bank on
it we're rich it's awesome that's
awesome serious well done
zach is in minnesota hi zach welcome to
the ramsay show
thanks thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
so i am about to start a new career in
real estate and
my wife and i are following your baby
steps finally after knowing them for so
long you're finally getting the zell
intense on them my question is
because
real estate is commission only should i
should we
build up our three to six months of
emergency fund before we really delve
into the debt snowballs no
but what you should do is you should
build an account not that you don't call
an emergency fund but that you use to
supplement your lack of income
that's different than an emergency
that's planning a career transition
and when i was in the real estate
business sometimes i had a month where i
made zero
and i might make twenty thousand bucks
the next month and so we always kept a
separate fund from our emergency fund
that we had a horrible name for it it
was called the hill and valley fund
when we were on the hill we set some
money back so when there was a valley
in other words if you were charting your
income and you saw hills and valleys
the hill and valley fund smoothed them
out does that make sense
yeah absolutely now here's the trick
six months in you should not need this
at all you should be making more than
you used to make total
and you should never look back
but but in your first six months your
income is going to be
at best volatile at worst non-existent
now is your wife work outside the home
she does she
is working at
a large department store while she is
finishing her master's degree
what is it you all are going to live on
um
we are well that's why i'm asking if we
should have
kind of some money stockpiled up because
she's making about 2 800
a month um
before taxes can you live on that and so
yeah we can live on that okay if you can
live on her income then you don't have
to have a lot stockpiled and here's the
maybe i'm reading into this man but
if you can't afford six months of making
zero salary it might be the need to
pause on taking a 100 commission job if
y'all can't eat
or you're gonna have to work on this job
and get after it all day and then go
find something and then at night and
drive so that y'all have some food yeah
yo 2800 if you guys can break even on
that then you don't need a fund
okay
if you if she can make enough you can
live on your wife's income till you get
your real estate business going there's
no
i mean it's just you just have to do
that you can't go up and go well we ran
up 30 000 in credit card debt while i
started my real estate no
no that would be stupid we're not using
the credit cards anymore yeah but i mean
you that's what people do and that's why
i'm saying it out loud so
yeah we we don't want to go that route
so you only need as big a fund as her
income won't cover for six months
and that's as big of fun as you need but
it's not really an emergency fund it's a
plan to transition
and uh so an emergency is an unexpected
event
this is expected we're we're expecting
this we can predict it
and then get out there and kick kick
butt and take names and let's go make a
bunch of money in the real estate
business so being straight commission in
and of itself does not require you have
an extra fund
um it might lean you towards the
six-month side in that three to six
months
spectrum
but uh
you know if you if you're a straight
commissioner and you make 300 000 a year
and you used to make 40 000 a year you
don't have a problem yeah you know and
so the the fact that something is
commissioned isn't the issue sometimes
if something's commissioned and it means
you don't make any money
it's not making money that's the issue
not the commissions
so um being self-employed is not the
issue the issue is being self-employed
not making money
so that that's that's what comes up in
people in these situations
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five dr john dolone's
new book own your past
change your future last week was number
one in the nation in
uh on all the best seller lists that
matter
and uh pretty cool so thank you guys we
appreciate you in america the book is a
not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
it has done very very well it's
continuing to sell
very fast in a world where we need to
have
some framework for coping
with the things we have gone through and
or are going through
and every one of us have things we go
through and or are going through
no one is an exception to that and and
we've had a
culture-wide experience in the past
24-36 months of this culture-wide stress
and anxiety level
and this gives you just some you know
okay that guy over there is usually not
a complete butt
so he must really be scared yeah
and it gives you a different way of
different framework of looking at things
and if you own your past
you say that's there that really
happened then you can change your future
that's right and we're heading into some
some strong headwinds with some some
negative financial information and we're
heading into some unstable political
it's going to be the rest of our lives
it's a thing will come up and then mom
will get sick and we'll get lose a job
life happens it's a love it's a
framework man for how to do life well
it's a way of it gives me skills
tools in my belt for we give you tools
in your belt for your career tools and
your belt for your money tools and your
belt for your relationships and your
mental wellness and that's what we do
here at ramsey and we do it here on the
ramsey show the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you wanna participate
i am dave ramsey your host and we'll be
back
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney number one best-selling
author of the book own your past and
change your future
is my co-host today as we take your
calls about your life and your money
it is a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five here on the
ramsey show we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create real
relationships
number two line is joseph calling from
savannah georgia to kick off this hour
what's up joseph
uh good afternoon gentlemen um
just uh where to call and uh ask for
some words of encouragement and um
help me as a to stay off losing
motivation i'm on baby step
number six uh currently working two jobs
and i've been praying
for god to help me with
discernment to see if uh
i should continue working the two jobs
um because the anxiety is just
it's getting to be a lot and
um
even though sending that big chunk to
the mortgage company every month feels
good
uh so you are debt-free except your
house
correct you're putting 15 of your income
into retirement
correct why are you working two jobs
uh because when i started this uh baby
step seven was always the goal um yeah
but we didn't teach you to stay gazelle
intense
after four we said move from intense to
intentional
you go from sprint to marathon when you
go into four five and six
so how many hours a week are you working
uh it's two full-time jobs
okay what do you make at your main job
um i'm making 80.
and what do you make of the second job
60. and what do you owe on your house
uh 240 are you married
no
you have kids
yes
your custody of the kids
about 50
and uh i'm covering tuition
what does a second job consist of
uh business analysts
so both of both works both jobs are
remote
so you're never off cut the second job
in half or by 75 or quit it completely
today
you don't need that 60k
dave and i both know a bunch of
millionaires who crossed that finish
line and they looked around and had
nothing
that's why we teach it the way we do
yeah
uh
you know you've
you know you've taken gazelle intensity
and put it over into those last several
baby steps and it's not sustainable yeah
the human body the human spirit you're
gonna you're running out of gas that's
why you're calling because you're you're
gasping for air and i don't blame you
you're listen you're not afraid of hard
work and you're actually not a
workaholic you're just so goal driven
and focus driven that you've run you've
run yourself out of your own shoes
when was your divorce
uh 2018
you still running
yes
you gotta stop
because that shadow's chasing you and
chasing you and chasing you and as the
sun moves that shadow gets faster and
longer it's gonna catch you there's
something uh that is a little bit
uh it feels like you're afraid if you
sit still you won't like what you hear
or see
am i wrong
um i think
being alone these last couple years
god has been teaching me to
listen to myself so
i've appreciated being alone and taking
the time to reflect um
i think
i don't know when you had that time
but the
hours listen listen
there is none zero there is no long-term
wellness there's no long-term time
long-term healing there's no long-term
life with joy in it that is done in
isolation and that is done with this
many hours right
in the job
two full-time jobs is it it's not
sustainable you can do it for two or
three years and you have
all right because you busted through the
first several baby steps and that's fine
i don't i'm not afraid of hard work i'm
not afraid of telling people to go work
hard but um you know if i the way i
answer questions here joseph is i woke
up in your shoes i'm three years old out
of a divorce i got 50
of my time with my babies and all i got
left to do is knock out the mortgage i'm
currently putting 15 of my income away i
make 80. i could easily take that 60
dollar back to 20 and i'd have so much
free time i wouldn't know what to do
with it and that's what i would do and
then you just kind of i want you to take
a deep breath and it feels like cold
mountain air in the morning coming into
your lungs that's called peace and just
feel it
and that's what i would want for you
that's what i would want to be if i were
you
um
and so
i i kind of did something similar and
i'm not accusing you of this
uh but but uh when we went through
bankruptcy
i worked like an absolute maniac the
other side of that because i was so
scared
and i didn't i didn't want to stop i
didn't want to i i didn't want to
dial it back and um
uh and it wasn't it wasn't a workaholism
it wasn't in that sense but but it was
just a running like john was saying and
so if i were in your shoes i'd dial it
back
yeah i think there's no question and i
want when you two dial it back brother i
want you to
make a commitment to yourself i'm gonna
go walk i'm gonna go to the gym a few
times a week
and i'm gonna get a group of guys and
we're gonna invite them over to the
house and we're gonna i don't know what
you're into we're gonna watch fights
we're gonna watch don't watch golf on tv
god help you but we're gonna get a group
of guys over together and we're gonna
watch something we're gonna do something
together and i'm gonna begin to build
back relationships in my life you had
two years of being in complete and total
isolation that anxiety alarm that you're
feeling is ringing off the wall because
your body is saying hey we're not we're
not we're not safe you called us because
you wanted us to tell you what you
already knew that's right it's time that
happens a lot around here dan is in
coeur d'alene idaho hi dan welcome to
the ramsey show
how are you doing today great man what's
up
hey i am 61 years old i will be in july
i i
just went through a divorce two years
ago and ended up selling the house and
bought a holiday trailer to live in
because i'm not going to pay for another
mortgage
and i have 170 000
that's
130 in cash and the rest in the mutual
fund
but i'm trying to figure out what i
should do for retirement because
i have friends that are younger than me
they haven't
uh
one had a stroke in the he can't drive
anymore
my health is not the greatest so trying
to figure out what to do
[Music]
what's what's uh what's wrong with your
health
i just got screwed up guts
it's good that's a bad back so bad
combination
okay
well you're not gonna be lifting
anything for a living are you working
oh yeah i'm a truck driver which is
really not great for either oil
i would like to get out of it and retire
but that my plan was to get the house
all paid off and
and just get a part-time job and kind of
enjoy life and
that kind of went out the window so yeah
um jump on
ramseysolutions.com and hit the smart
investor pro button and find a
smartvestor pro that can advise you on
helping you get some of that 170 000
invested it's sitting in a savings
account not making any money and also
set you up as a roth ira and some other
things to get some investing going so we
can get your nest egg up a little better
so you can relax here in the next couple
years it sounds like other than that
you're on your way
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money if you've taken financial
peace university you know it's
life-changing
it's hard to watch your friends and
family struggle with money when you know
there's a way you know there's hope
uh now you can actually help them
change their family tree just like you
did when you give them a ramsay plus
gift card it bundles everything that
they need to win with money into one
gift it includes financial peace
university a year of the premium version
of every dollar the every dollar
absolute connects to your bank and now
we've also added unlimited group
coaching from our team of financial
coaches so coaching every dollar
financial peace university wow
a ramsey plus gift card listen to this
all of that that's that should be like
500 worth of stuff
99 bucks and that's a year's access
99 bucks that's a d that's a hookup man
that's a d on it i think we made a
mistake but okay but it's really it's
it's this is this is the best thing we
do around here and one of the best
things we do around here and man so
ramsay solutions dot com slash gift get
a ramsey plus gift card for just 99
bucks you can give this to a
friend maybe you know somebody's getting
ready to graduate hello getting ready to
get married it's wedding and graduation
season gift card 99 bucks get some
everything
and uh here's the thing they can't throw
it in the
back closet and not get it out for five
years because it's only good for a year
so they got to go do it and they can't
buy something stupid on amazon with that
gift card so get them a gift card that's
actually going to change their life you
mean their stupid stuff on amazon i've
bought my share of stupid stuff
it reminds me it goes like every you
know once a year this morning here's
what you bought this morning no not this
not this morning but it says if you
don't want to buy stupid stuff on amazon
the best thing to do stay away from
rachel cruz here's here's the here's
what you bought last year and i look at
it and go uh oh man i really needed i
those special don't even know what that
does but i hit the button and got it
delivered yeah oh
all right david's in dallas hi david how
are you
hey dave and tom it's great to talk to
you and pick your brains on something
today sure what's up
uh well i'm 56
i've got 228 000 in six different debts
including two student loans my wife's
undergrad
uh and then my
parent plus loan for my kid who has been
on your show doing a debt-free screen
back in 2018
um and then also master's work that i
did
and y'all are educated up around there i
hope you're making money what's your
household income
uh about 150. that's good okay actually
about 160 now come think of it
um so what i'm trying to figure out is
given
you know my age given the debt level um
is it wise for me just to stick with
baby step two
or to
go ahead and start putting some into
roth
to start making some headway there what
do you and your wife do for a living
tournament
we both work in education
she's a teacher and i work in i.t
what do you do in i.t
i'm a
director i manage email voicemail
telephone systems all the
my group handles everything that all the
end users touch
so you're making how much of the 160
uh about 102
okay
are you allowed in your current contract
to take any side consulting gigs
yes good you need some
so here's
here's what
number one the answer your question is
no you don't need to go get a roth ira
the instead what you need is a vision
for paying off this debt very very
quickly so that you're not panicked
about the fact that you have no
retirement so what if i said let's go
completely out of our minds bizarre for
two years and be debt free you guys both
are high intellect you're both very
intellectual people and if you're not
careful you're going to think yourself
out of a visceral response to this
problem which is the fastest way out i
want you to get so pissed off that your
eyes are bleeding and your brain quits
thinking and all you do is go make money
like a maniac and get your income up at
two and a quarter and live on beans and
rice and you don't need to see the
inside of a restaurant unless you're
working there and if you even get on
amazon again i'm gonna throw your
computer in the dead gum trash and oh by
the way you're not going on vacation you
need to get your butt in gear and get
this mess cleaned up that kind of
emotion instead of using intellect to
fix this problem because you use
intellect to fix everything because
you're so freaking smart
well if i were that smart i wouldn't be
in this
hey man
you are both you are both highly
educated very analytical people am i
right
pretty much yeah and so you're trying to
figure out a way around this is why you
called
and instead i'm throwing dynamite in the
middle of this thing
blowing you up man
well i mean i i do pick up uh stuff
that's primarily in the fall
it goes basically from august through
january ish and and i'm trying to add to
it for the spring i mean i end up
picking up additional stuff through work
working games where i pick up you know
four to six thousand dollars a year
additional
i just said i'm talking about enough i'm
talking about fifty thousand yeah that's
five bucks i mean that's 50 bucks a pop
you you gotta make more than that i'm
talking about 50 grand you're in an
industry where you can contract out and
manage it from your home while your wife
is asleep and go bananas that you're and
i don't want you to do this for very
long
but but i want you to have no life so
that late so that very quickly you have
a life again because here's the thing
let's pretend that you lost your mind
and people thought you were crazy like
i'm describing and you guys just went
bananas you scorched earth on the
lifestyle and in two years you were free
at 58. how rich are you going to be
making by then probably 180 000 a year
without working crazy
and having no payments in the world for
the first time in your recent memory
you're gonna have so much margin that
you're gonna be able to throw so much
money you're you'll probably be worth in
excess of a million dollars by the time
you get to 65 starting at 58.
but you have this barrier in front of
you and you have two years of hell
to bust that barrier can y'all do that
yeah the only challenge we have is our
our daughter single parent of an infant
and having to care for her sometimes and
my wife having to juggle working late
sometimes but we can figure that piece
out
it can also be it can also be a really
challenging conversation
sitting down with your daughter saying
we're going to be able to we've got this
plan
which is going to benefit you and this
young granddaughter in the long run
exponentially more than scattershot
babysitting here in the current
well no it's not that is she works 787p
and there is no daycare okay
that we found anyway we found
inexpensive daycare 45 bucks a day while
she is at work and while we're at work
but when we get home one of us is there
watching that doesn't mean that i can't
go ahead and work
doing it stuff etc so
so
here's the thing um
yeah there's a lot going on and you have
some barriers
the truth is though the best way to get
where you want to be not the barriers
the best way you well there are
obstacles uh there are things you have
to work through whatever it is you can
call them we can call them whatever we
want to call them but the best way to be
where you want to be
uh
nine years from today is what i just
described we're thinking about it go get
it done the highest probability
of you getting there in the shortest
amount of time is what i described
from all of my 30 years of doing this i
don't know a better way and it and it is
not a better way to limp into retirement
with three different kinds of student or
four different kinds of student loans
hanging around your neck and you've got
a half butt roth ira right and that's
where you'll be nine years from now if
you try to just short circuit this
system instead of punching this thing in
the nose
and but there's something that has to
happen
inside of your
deep down where you growl that's not
your brain yes
it's the i've had it moment and you're
just howling at the moon and you're
going no more i've worked my butt off i
got this stupid parent plus loan i've
got this kid single with a single mom
one of my grandbabies and i love them
dearly but dead gum what a mess oh my
gosh and i gotta fight through this and
there's something you're just going to
double up your fist and just get after
it and that's the best way out of this
it's the fastest way out and i don't
know a better way
a modified version of that to tell you
if i did i would because it's gonna i'm
what i'm prescribing is a horrible two
years
i want you to have a miserable two years
so the next 25 are excellent there you
go
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsay
solutions on the debt-free
stage
kyle and corrine are with us hey guys
how are you great how are you better
than i deserve so good to have you where
do you guys live bellingham washington
bellingham washington bit of a hall to
nashville it was well it's good to have
you thank you for joining us how much
debt have you paid off 273 thousand
dollars
how long did that take about five years
good for you and your range of income
during that time about 92 to 140. good
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
police officer and i'm a part-time
speech-language pathologist very good
cool so five years and 273 000 in
bellingham washington was that your
house we're weird
looking talking to weird people
yeah i love it very cool what's this
house worth right now it's around 7 50
probably
yeah 80 when that happens
i love it how old are you two i'm 39 i'm
38. not even 40 with a paid for three
quarters of a million dollar house yes
y'all are y'all are truly weird
how much is in your 401k is your
retirement stuff uh enough to probably
tip us over to that everyday millionaire
status way to go baby steps millionaires
whoa
look at you you did it man and not even
40 years old no and by the way a police
officer and a part-time speech path
paid off their house before 40. not
brain scientists not they're not fixing
rockets no actually you're fixing
neighborhoods which is harder right for
real but yes we're not making millions
of dollars here man and they figured it
out dude i got to hear the story what
happened this is incredible yeah how'd
you do this uh so we bought a new house
and uh we kept our old one as a rental
because we just that's what people do i
guess and then about a year into it we
decided that was not really good for us
so i started researching whether we
should sell that house or not and that's
how i tripped on your materials
and after that we decided to sell it we
put all that money down on our current
house the new house that we bought i was
messing around with excel and you could
see how much you would save by putting
that amount of money forty thousand
dollars down on it and it was just
incredible oh it blows your mind yeah
and so then i should got rid of the
hassle
right yes that was my life and mostly
him he took care of yeah
it's not pain in the butt yeah it is
yeah it wasn't for us um
so then i just deep dived into your
material dave uh i just kept going to
crin and saying okay you know let's put
you know a little extra money on the
house and we can get it paid off early
and i just say okay sounds good i come
back to ourselves okay i think we can do
a little bit more totally fine and then
a little bit more and it just kept going
like that
when did you finally say enough
i didn't
no i mean i was i was on board i i
really he incrementally warmed you up to
where you didn't even realize how crazy
you got
i just trusted him completely with the
finances he kind of handled it and i
she's sweet well and i just i mean he
would talk to me about it and when he
showed me that excel spreadsheet and
said we're gonna save this much
that was powerful
then on that basis we're doing this
i like that as much as i trusted him
okay yes i looked at the numbers and
then i trusted him
well and then i think what really
happened is cove it happened and then
that's when i well he'd always listen to
you um actually one time i even asked
him in the car i said why do you listen
to him you know all the answers because
he would spout him out before you
and um
covet hit and and news was just gloomy
and sad and everybody was depressing so
i thought i'm gonna i'm gonna listen to
dave ramsey and i got hooked you were
hopeful and you were upbeat and you you
and john deloney specifically just
helped in those very early months of
covid for me
and i started listening and thinking
this this is actually something i want
to do and you offered financial peace
for free and so we watched it at home
after the girls would go to bed
and
as i
i watched all your classes i realized oh
man our opportunities will increase if
we do this if we pay off the house
and then also your generosity video
really spoke to me i was like i want to
be that person that offers to pay for
somebody at the grocery store which i've
done once and he turned me down
um
and and that's where we just
really started dialing it up i think
that going through that class really
clicked into why and for me it was like
man what does this future look like with
the girls what kind of trips can we do
for them pay for their college maybe buy
them a home later in life and then for
corinne it was for the girls it was for
education i didn't really want to go
public schools and i wanted to have that
opportunity to either do homeschool or
private school and without having the
financial burden of a mortgage it just
allowed me to either go par you know
even more part-time or quit my job or
private and
just opportunities
wow
way to go you guys you're amazing well
done so powerful the last 24-36 months
has been real tough on police officers
how have you kept your foot on the gas
at home while also navigating a really
just a tough work environment uh great
question i wasn't prepared for that one
um
yeah you know
that goes to kind of like how you do it
and i think it's just really
intentionality for us was
we just had that goal and it sort of
drove what we chose to do and what we
chose not to do in our lives and i've
just found that you're successful at
what you're intentional at and so
we really dove into the the house
and i wouldn't say we made huge
sacrifices but it was just consistent
choices and then i think that's the same
at work too is you just have to make
consistent choices of
i'm here to do this i'm here to serve my
community i want to make a difference
and i just got to keep reminding myself
that because there is a whole lot of
people that will tell you that you're
there for a different reason yeah that's
incredible yeah
i i'm not you know i read the other day
a guy said i'm not responsible
for the narrative of me that you have in
your head that's right
but that idea if i tell you what
you just summed up therapy you summed up
workout programs diet programs
goals are
a function of what you're intentional
about period in
business you just summed it up right
there that's incredible guys
you're well done not even 40. so i'm not
getting i don't know how to wrap my head
around it yeah it's beautiful beautiful
pretty how does it feel to not have a
payment in the world
uh it feels great
yeah
it's still a little weird i i have to
admit i had i haven't really felt it yet
but yeah i don't know it's kind of
surreal yeah it's very certain to not
even be 40 and i think both of us
secretly had a little
goal to do this before we were 40. so
not a secret anymore yeah it's not the
secret's out you did it
i love it i can't wait till uh
kyle you're gonna pull somebody over in
about six months and they're gonna be
like ooh millionaire giving me a ticket
that's what i'm talking about
it's going to happen that's going to
happen next week
oh my god congratulations intimidating
now
that's always been hard for me
oh my goodness well done you guys we got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you you should be in the book you did it
exactly the way that uh is laid out here
five years they pay off their mortgage
from the time they set the goal 750 000
paid for home
at um not even 40 years old also a copy
total money makeover you can give that
away to somebody and continue to spread
the ruckus that we're causing out here
in america we're trying to stir it up
and we appreciate all you guys out there
helping us do
just that spread the word about the
podcast spread the word about the
debt-free screams spread the word about
dr john's number one best-selling book
spread the word about the number one
bestseller baby steps millionaires
because i'm sitting here looking at two
of them boom this stuff is real people
this stuff is real i'm so proud of y'all
it works yeah it really does yeah we got
a great story about the the total money
makeover crain came to me was like i'm
not sure who who we're going to give the
book to right and i was like don't worry
god will tell us who to give it to and
the next day
she came to some with somebody that said
hey i want to talk to you about that
dave ramsey guy there it is just like
that all right let's bring the girls up
what are their names and ages
penny is six and hattie is three all
right we're gonna do our debt-free
scream house and everything those two
right there have had their lives changed
their family tree has changed by their
brave courageous mom and dad 273 000
paid off in five years making 92 to 140
house and everything
baby steps millionaires before their 40
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three
two one we're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
i love it
so cool man as rachel always says
there was a day i was that little girl
yep man goes quick this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today exodus 15 13 in your
unfailing love you will lead the people
you have redeemed in your strength you
will guide them to your holy dwelling
joe dimaggio said a person always doing
his or her best becomes a natural leader
just
by
example dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five shane is with us in
cleveland ohio hi shane welcome to the
ramsey show
hey thank you both it's an honor to be
speaking with you you too what's up
hey so my question is this i guess a
little context my wife and i discovered
your program two years ago
which a lot of happened in the last few
years obviously very thankful for that
and we are we'll be in baby step seven a
year from today is our plan
and my question to you is
does it ever make sense to have more
than one financial advisor in your
corner
what would be the purpose
so we've been looking through the elps
we've been shopping around and we found
some really great people in our area and
they're just a few that we really like
and we're just curious if it makes sense
to maybe give a little bit of money one
and then a little bit of money to the
other and see who performs better is
that just over complicating things or
does it make sense to do that i i try to
keep things as simple as possible yeah
um
it's using the tool wrong
it's not up to them to perform it's up
to you to perform
it's up to them to teach you
and you make the decisions
and if both of them are teaching you and
they're giving you slightly different uh
teaching then you're just going to be
confused
um so i would use one
but you don't want to you're not handing
them the money as a test and going okay
who wins the race
because they're not in the race you are
you see the difference yeah that makes a
lot of sense yeah and so
um
[Music]
you know i don't get two tax guys to run
my our tax people to run my uh tax
returns and see who wins
i need my taxes done right with the most
possible
uh money not going to the government the
least money going to the government
possible
and um you know so that that's the goal
that is legal and moral and
you know
we just came through an audit which is
the first time i've gotten that
wonderful um
inspection of my body parts it's like
right yeah unbelievable and it came out
you know what i came out with
owing zero
wow that's how good we are because we're
fanatics about the integrity of doing it
properly right yeah we don't lie we
don't cut corners we don't cheat i hate
taxes i hate that the government takes
so much of my money but i'm gonna do it
exactly right so it's my job to make
sure that the stuff's filed right and i
use an an advisor a a professional in
that corner yeah i i just learned to
play golf i've been learning to play
golf i'm not any good in the last three
years
and one of the best pieces of advice i
got and everybody's got a freaking
opinion about golf i've never seen a
sport
with as much
diverse
stupid stuff in it i mean my god
and so but one of the the single best
piece of advice i guess don't get more
than one coach
because they'll just they'll make you
schizophrenic at your golf swing and you
know make you multiple personalities
with your golf swing whatever whatever
the phrase is it's a metaphor here but
um anyway so yeah i i i sorry i got one
guy and i'm doing that one when i cease
to
believe that he's moving me to the next
level then i'll get a different guy well
and that's what i heard here is
i like them i want to i want to prove i
want them to prove themselves to me if
you don't trust the person yeah with
your retirement account that's teaching
you go to somebody else but the proving
needs to be did i learn something and am
i comfortable making these choices
because they showed me how to handle my
money not because i handed it to them
and one of them does better than the
other and or they gave me some magic
dust package that was going to exist
right the financial world is full of
those people yes yep that's exactly
right that that's what we're looking for
so that's a really good question
but yeah i use one
uh insurance professional
i use one
real estate professional
my son-in-law i used one uh
you know i i won golf coach
uh one uh
smart investor pro oh that makes sense
because i'd sent you an email back just
asking if i could help you with your
golf swing and you never wrote back
i now understand it wasn't because of me
it's because i have played golf with
happy gilmore
you know the running you know the
running swing that gilmore has as he
runs at the ball with a driver i'm not
great this is john i'm not great i play
with john and john drove a 310 yard
green on the 18th green he drove the
green 310 yards the rest of the day he
drove the woods
with style hey man i mean i'm not great
i don't know how many balls he started
with i know how many he ended with all
hey i borrowed some of these clubs
because i don't have my own and uh a
week later they like hey man you owe me
like 20 bucks yeah you tore up my club
balls
used up their golf ball twenty bucks hey
man i sent golf balls all over world
where no that was 200 bucks
20 bucks wouldn't bought those golf
balls i'm not great dave i'm not great
not great yeah that's well you brought
it up i you brought up coaching me so
i'm just saying
uh i'm not great but i'm
not happy gilmore you're better than me
uh i was afraid we're going to go into
that in the pond with that alligator and
get some of those back
oh
thank you thank you adam sandler for the
memories
uh all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
timothy's in washington dc hi timothy
how are you
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
so i have just started a brand new job
coincidentally in the federal government
working for the library of congress in
their braille music division
and
i am very illiterate when it comes to
benefits and retirement and stuff i've
heard my parents talk about it but i
never actually pursued it very deeply to
learn all the ins and outs of what each
thing means
i've been in touch a little bit with
your smartvestor pros and
they told me i should need to get a
financial cushion under my belt first
before i think about investing
and um so i just wanted to find out from
you
what your advice would be to someone
who's 28 years old just starting at work
and
basically starting from the bare bones
bottom i have no debt
not at all yeah you're ahead you're way
ahead brother congratulations actually
people don't start from the bottom they
usually start from subterranean and they
have to get dig up to the bottom but
yeah you are starting the bottom but hey
congratulations so braille music is that
what you said
yes sir that's so cool are you braille
literate
i'm assuming so i'm very cool man
are you sight impaired blind i'm sorry
yes i am i'm totally blind okay wow good
for you man that's a great job rockstar
dude that is so cool
all right so
the process will not be any different
and so what you're saying is is that i
don't even have the basic
uh tool set i need a starter tool set to
get going with this whole money thing
agreed well i've got financial peace i
do i'm in the ramsey plus membership
okay so
yeah obviously the uh audio
of all of that is very valuable to you
then
oh yes and then i do have access to some
of your books electronically there's a
website called bookshare that has a lot
of your material yep yep we tried to
make sure they get it so that's good and
we appreciate them carrying it so the uh
good good okay so that's it i mean
you're gonna work the baby steps you're
gonna make sure you have the proper uh
insurances in place and that's one of
your lessons in financial peace
university you're going to uh you know
make sure you get your emergency fund in
place which is what your smart investor
pro told you to do and then you're gonna
start investing and uh you said it's a
federal employ federal government
employee right
yes sir okay so you've got the tsp
available to you
and when you start doing that you're
going to investigate you're probably
going to want to do about 80
in the c
about 10 in the s and about 10 in the i
uh that small company and international
the c is common stock it's about like an
s p 500 fund and if you put money in
those for uh a couple decades you'll
probably be a millionaire
if you load them up that's awesome and
so you'll be on your way and uh you're
right on track you're a neat guy man
that's so cool i'm glad to hear that i
didn't even know that existed that the
braille music
that's so cool the library congress is i
know it's fascinating
but i mean that's amazing very cool good
show john and james and ben and
everybody in the booth everybody thank
you thank you thank you that puts this
hour of the day from the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to
slash
ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you